50 ans que vous êtes avec votre mari
Patrick 52 ans
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai jamais dépassé trois ans 52 ans
c'est quoi le secret
il y en a j'ai un expression française
en français il y en a que j'aime pas
mais cela j'aime beaucoup avoir des
atomes crochus
en fait un entité quoi et sans lui on
n'est pas tout à fait vivement j'ai pas
toujours été des belles phrases au
quotidien
c'est offert par la maison
je crois que c'est alors là je vais
faire un comparaison avec mon métier
c'est à dire avant tout c'est pas faire
le disque de faire de la scène ce qui
compte sur la scène c'est de donner mais
c'est surtout de surprendre et ce qui
compte entre vous et votre
éventuellement marie ou votre femme etc
c'est de la donner et de la surprendre
ou de lui de se prendre tout le temps et
c'est plus facile de se prendre en
amenant par exemple à Venise
du bouillon c'est plus facile de
surprendre c'est sûr
et rire en France
il a dit pour la pour la surprendre un
beau dessin
la descente du Rhône sur une péniche non
un poème un copain et tout c'est super
mignon le principal c'est que ça vienne
du coeur